[Music]
Rodrigo told me he had this new script
and then it was slightly Blown Away by
the actual script itself because it's a
really interesting story really
cheapest man who ever lived it's as old
as time the stories of Fathers and Sons
the brothers are here very reluctantly
they are half Brothers they both shared
this father and he was a terrible father
to them they haven't even seen him in
years and they hear that his last wish
is that they dick his grave and then you
are to lower the casket and cover the
grave again
what
[Music]
Ethan and I I always thought that we
would end up in a movie together but
it's taken like 30 years for that to
happen so it was lovely to finally get a
chance to work together to throw
ourselves into these incredible scenes
his last wish was that his sons attend
his funeral you don't have to go
he's dead he'll never know
you're a very tender man you know that
the humor and vulnerability of these
brothers it really moved me hi how did
you know our father
we were lovers for a while
actually this film explores human nature
that's why it hits you in such a deep
way it's moving and true and very funny
what would you like as a father
the worst your father's wish was to be
buried naked why is he face down it's
what he requested they had the best
movies start at the end
you know as you're walking out of the
theater when a movie starts vibrating
inside your head with how it relates to
your own life I hope it's a movie that
rings that Bell that sounds long after
it's been wrong hey